he's a sort of an assassin he shows up
on set knows every line has you know all
jokes he's got improv Xand he's really
thought about it so it was just a
delight that they've come up here to
tell us how great it's gonna be for all
of us to become Americans we were on set
with Rob Lowe and the entire Super
Troopers to cast down in Boston where
Rob gave us that evil Quebec Mayor vibe
with an excellent accent to go along
with it I have so many Canadian friends
that I've been picking and choosing my
Canadian isms to use and it's been
really fun for these ghosts how would
you grade his french-canadian accent a
A+ A+ eh in the sequel the super
troopers face off against Rob and his
Mountie goons maybe it has something to
do with running out of maple syrup from
the first movie
come on thorny you're losing to the
rookie it's embarrassing come on rabbit
you can do it it would not be good for
your system for sure that's nothing it's
like you know just not a whole bottle
now the sequel hits theaters April 20th
4:20 and if it blazes up the box-office
I think we'll try to make Super Troopers
three winter soldiers you know set in
the dead of winter
we'll do a beer fest sequel so that's
another thing that you know if we have
the opportunity to jump right into that
we'd love to do that too I like it well
if you need a Canadian reporter
you're hired
[Music]